[Music]
everyone at South by Southwest
Interactive is looking to disrupt the
status quo with technology from cowboy
hat wearing robot arms to stress
detecting aromatherapy diffuser to
futuristic speakers that make you feel
like a band is playing in your living
room but at a panel discussion during
the festival we may have found a group
of people with the most disruptive ideas
out there dissidents using tech to
disrupt authoritarian regimes the people
right there they don't have luck
satellites they don't have internet they
have nothing so to be stuck only with
Isis propaganda it will affect them if
you are a new trend on average a trend
that just follow the state media the
Arab Spring never happens Gaddafi still
alive you still in power Mubarak is
still in power because it was never
reported Taliban and many of the
conservative leaders trying to restrict
the information because it's a way for
them to hold the power and deny the
rights and freedom and we needed to
change that we put information in flash
drives in really in cities we spread the
voice in the past you could do books or
in the former Soviet Union some is Dada
or underground you know magazines and
whatnot
now in the device it's only this big you
can pack it with thousands of hours of
reading or or hundreds of hours of film
and video and television and that really
can be a true game changer you can
imagine how many USB drives are floating
around South by Southwest so the human
rights foundation exhibit on the
convention floor encouraged attendees to
drop off drives over later be filled
with films and information from the
outside world and then smuggled into
North Korea all the thumb drives you see
here were actually placed here by people
who are walking around and it's their
way of literally shoving it in the
mouths of Kim jong-un the dictator of
North Korea the struggle for freedom is
one that used to be about who has more
guns now it really information is a key
component in ensuring that the
government doesn't get away with winning
the day with its narrative and pushing
what governments tend to do which is the
use of fear to control the population
ignorance and fear
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]